Here are the solutions. Nice work if you got even half of these right. Now some
of these might have been tricky, like the second one or even this last one.
Let's walk through each of these to see how they're done. To find f plus g of
1, we need to add the outputs of f of 1 and g of 1 together. To find f of 1 we
take x and set it equal to 1 for this function. So, if we plug in a 1 here and
here in for x, then we'll get an output of positive 1. Next we need to find g
of 1. To find g of 1 we let x equal 1 for this function. So, we'll have 3 times
1 minus 5, which equals negative 2. We have f of 1 equal to 1 and g of 1 equal
to negative 2. So, we just add these two outputs together to get a final output
of negative 1. To find the second one, f minus g of 1, we'll take the output
from g of 1, negative 2, and we'll subtract that from the output f of 1, which
equals 1. So notice I'll have 1 here minus negative 2. When we subtract a
negative, we really add. So we'll have 1 plus 2 which equals positive 3. This
is our output for f minus g of 1. For f times g of 1, we'll simply multiply
these two outputs together. So, 1 times negative 2 equals negative 2. Now to
find f divided by g of 2, we want to find f of 2 and divided it by g of 2. To
find f of 2 we plug in 2 in for x. This would give us an output of 2. 2 squared
equals 4, minus 4 is 0 plus 2 is 2. And for g of 2 we'll let the input x equal
positive 2, which means we'll get an output of positive 1. We'll have 6 minus 5
which equals 1. Now we're ready to do our division, this is f of 2 and this is
g of 2. We have 2 divided by 1 which equals 2. And finally to find f plus g of
x, we'll simply add these two functions together. So, combining the like terms
of x, we'll get one x and combining our constant terms we'll have negative 3.
So, the overall function is x squared plus x minus 3, f plus g of x.